amidst all the coronavirus gloom that
can be hard to find the positive so
behold this captain Tom Moore completing
a hundred laps of his garden most ninety
nine year old World War two veterans
could be forgiven for putting their feet
up in taking things easy
knock Tom congratulations he's wowed the
UK and raised an astonishing amount of
money for the health service that people
will be so kind to give their source of
money to the National Health Service and
maybe I I wasn't forceful for starting
it but not not deliberately it was deep
you lose you gotta chew for what they've
done for me on Friday he was applauded
at his home by emergency service staff
but the extraordinary achievement of
captain Tom Moore and the immense
generosity and goodwill amongst the
British public at the moment towards
doctors and nurses in hospitals like
this around the country it all raises a
big question why does the NHS need such
charity the healthcare academic Anita
Charlesworth explains that even though
the NHS is tax funded it's always
received donations ministers have
certainly been keen to show their
support coming out weekly to join public
applause for healthcare errs but
coronavirus has highlighted cracks in
the system a lack of virus testing and
protective equipment for medics has
become a national scandal the decade of
austerity means NHS funding has not kept
pace with demand this is run for Heroes
another campaign set up to help doctors
and nurses fighting coronavirus perhaps
the epidemic will boost NHS funding in
the long term says its young founder I
don't know if our government is giving
enough right now towards it and you know
I hope after this we realize the
importance of the NHS because you know
as British public we're so lucky to have
it and it's so clear from this campaign
the people are so behind it and you know
that NHS means so much to them donations
and applause landmarks lit up in blue in
the time of coronavirus love for the NHS
is a sentiment that's echoed around the
country
Rory challon's al-jazeera London